okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are talking about a
somewhat complicated design issue about
Wolfram language we have a variety of
places where we are
[Music]
picking from
a limited set of options and we don't
have a uniform way to do this okay so
let's let's dig into what we're talking
about here so this came up we have
things like dollar font families okay
so dollar font families is a great big
list of fonts right
we similarly have dollar voice styles is
that right yeah which is a list of
potential voices to use for the forum
speech synthesis right we also have a
list so devices if I say find what do I
say I say find devices I think and it
will go ahead and try and find devices
on my computer system interesting okay
all kinds of random junk color schemes
how would I expose the color schemes we
have
Roger or brat can you say something sir
color schemes is sort of a hierarchy so
there's the palette and programmatically
you would say color scheme or color data
of gradients okay so color schemes has a
palette right now and then is it Roger
here by the way
no I don't think so was he was he
supposed to be here no okay
all right so we've got a palette there
and you say if I say color data I also
get a list there or if I say top level
list and then within that okay so
another thing we've got here in this
list is example data that's another
place where we have sort of a pickable
list of things okay
and that's multilevel also right musical
instruments how do we get that list
we don't have a programmatic way of
getting those yet okay that's just in
the documentation okay so now we've also
got things like system model or examples
I mean I think that's some kind of weird
gallery thing right
um okay so okay so the question then is
the the front end also has an
undocumented way to reproduce a number
of its menus that it populates I can
throw something in the chat as an
example if that's useful yep and it
returns there's a list of rules for the
particular example that I pasted that
doesn't seem to make a lot of sense but
there are a few cases where it does
where the left-hand side of the rule
might be different from the right-hand
side for what you would want to you know
feed to a pop up menu okay but so
another thing is the styles list
front-end styles list right there you
know there are several things that the
front-end generates like this in fact
dollar font families is initially
sourced by the front end but then we put
a documented wrapper around it okay so
another one is the current value
settings current value choices the list
of what current values there are yeah
and that's not something that is
probable at the moment
fair enough but okay so I mean we have a
whole bunch of these things I mean in
the general case we have like method
option settings all kinds of things like
that um but the basic issue is
you
what
[Music]
okay so interactively we see
auto-completion for example the somebody
on the live stream is pointing out that
color data has this nice choose color
scheme thing yes I agree um and you know
that's a good way to do it um although
apparently it has a bug I'm being told
here
you
obviously broken to me on the Mac at
least um
Oh Janice transpired I don't know quite
what that means then in that case are
you using master Branchville I am using
they're very old
11:3 okay if you try it again I think
you might see the dollar version stuff
below it or through it
oh that's absolutely crazy that's that's
funky did we fix that it seems familiar
I think I've completely forgotten about
it but I don't know having been fixed
okay okay well something to fix Norris
can you make sure that's an open bug yep
okay um all right so how do I expose the
start list of styles in the front end
from the front end well I mean I just
well that that's the list of styles it
goes into the Styles menu there is no
way to get a complete list of styles
complete list of styles would be quite
overwhelming anyway okay okay
okay fair enough all right okay so let's
come back then to the question of how
this stuff should work so for example
this example they took what will
complete in the right way no that's
pathetic
well well typing it does but example
data could perfectly well have a picker
you know so now for example this sum if
I say sound note 0 1 ok so that does
have an autocomplete there okay
but it doesn't have the ability to say
so that gives you the interactive way to
get these things with an autocomplete
but what we don't have is a way to
expose that list for programmatic use
well echoes it goes the other way too I
mean there are people who would like to
implement this functionality for their
own functions so that they can get the
autocompletes they wants and we have no
documented way of doing that it can be
done but no documented way what have we
done with auto-completion for user
functions and annika in general do we
have a mechanism for that now no well I
mean yes and no yes we have some
mechanisms whose design I'm not entirely
proud of but but you know they're not
documented that's the syntax information
mechanism is that right no this doesn't
do auto completion syntax information is
about things like argument counts and
that kind of thing it has nothing to do
with not usable
I believe so to be perfectly honest it's
one of those things I haven't had a
chance to sit down play with the recent
years Wow it's been a decade um I don't
use the word years lately okay do we
think that users are using this to set
syntax information actually good
immediate question on this part should
check into this with Brad Ashley are we
using this in the function Pacolet
business because we certainly could
okay I'll ask you okay also I wonder
whether this is in the guide pager is
about setting up functions and things it
should be um
that's another thing to check in to
birth but let's not get derailed on this
right now okay so I mean
you know basically this is part of
something like syntax information could
be an autocomplete a specification of
how to autocomplete things right yes
possibly I mean to be honest this this
thing is a is a pre Association this
should really be an association well
that's certainly true and given that
it's an association we could perfectly
well add a bunch of things in there for
auto completion I mean we need auto
completion trees for these things but
which we have a way to define it okay
this is a separate thing who should be
dealing with this syntax information
thing to begin with well so we have a
stake in it but it can't just be us
though the I'm not sure who on the
kernel side would be an appropriate
person to be working on this because
frankly I'm not sure what all issues
come up but but it can't just be the
front-end team why is there a kernel
component that's significant here well I
mean among other things this is you know
this is this is a specification of the
Wolfen language yeah no I understand but
but but okay so that we need to branch
up and and and we have to figure out you
know how this information gets
communicated to the front-end you know
it's there are lots of inefficient ways
to communicate it to the front end of
course but whatever way it's
communicated right now I mean is this
actually being communicated right now or
is this no this is built I mean yes it
is possible to to communicate this stuff
but you know it is possible like a
package loading loading time to send a
bunch of stuff like when you load the
package basically
well so whatever mechanism exists for
that could be used okay um let's let's
come back here so this is one thing
but the other question is what is the
programmatic way to expose a list like
this so we've got a whole bunch of these
things yeah and you know the other thing
to remember is that you know there's a
parameterization here sometimes you know
it may be the third argument of sound
notes but maybe the third argument is
sound notes is exactly the same as the
second argument of some other function
sure right so okay so plot themes is
there a way to programmatically get the
list of plot themes there is an internal
variable that contains them although I
don't know that it's really used for
anything right okay okay but so what
we're discovering here is there are lots
of these cases where there's sort of a
so we need some mechanism you know there
are sort of associated lists of things
that show up okay okay so let's throw
out some possible places this could go
okay so one somewhat bizarre place but I
don't think it's obviously crazy is the
data repository
okay
so in other words I think that's
instantly out of date
what do you mean and it can always be
updated so I mean it could say resource
data you know musical instrument list
and that would then you know we would
document that and that would then return
the list how do you deal with versioning
issues data repository I have a
mechanism for doing that it does but
it's not particularly exposed its
intended to be a data for all time type
of thing but I mean what's your point
your point is my point is first of all
that there may be good reason to have
these lists be different between one
released version and another and and
secondly that we need the ability to do
developments in a way that doesn't break
production okay well I mean we can have
a version you know we could have okay if
we're gonna discuss this we should get
somebody we should get probably Brad
Ashby here we can do that I'll look for
thanks the other thing is that many of
these things are going to be user
dependent right now so what the list of
styles is or what the list of fonts is
or yeah styles isn't just user dependent
is notebook dependent yeah all right
okay so what about an alternative
mechanism something called like system
data that then has a bunch of string
names so for example you'd say system
data so then we document a large
collection of these things and each one
you know we could say system data of
font families system data of whatever
thoughts about that I like that better
there are still some things that don't
really belong to the system you know the
style example being a case but but but
certainly font families belongs to the
system in some sense
I mean rumors system data well what
would you want to call it I mean I don't
know but system data implies you know
that that you can you know that if you
don't change the system that you can
evaluate it's over and over again and
get the same results and for you know if
in the Styles example that is most
definitely not true because it's
notebook dependent yes okay so well what
would you could then call it well I'm
really good at criticisms I mean this is
not good that would be like current
value okay so another possibility is to
use the current value mechanism yeah I
mean in that particular for certainly
for that particular case and perhaps for
others current value makes a certain
sort of sense the provides scoping and
all kinds of good stuff for families
right now yeah no at least not not that
I can think of the real problem with
current value is that like a few other
functions it's minoo it's become I mean
it's it's a bit of a dumping ground I
mean there is some very well-defined
things about current value but then
there are some things where it's just
like well it's just uh you know a new
string that behaves this way and a new
string the PAS that way well I mean yes
so let's take a look at what current
value currently has in it so to speak is
there a list of current values well
there's a list in the help no but what
about I mean so current value no you
can't query it programmatically
now right so that would be a fork I
understand it's not going to work I'm
just making them okay let's take a look
at the help and and and there you know
there are two very different uses of
current value I mean you know one is one
is for option like things and the other
is for these you know properties that
there that are not settable but are
quería ball
yeah I mean it is weird that some of
these things are dollar sign accessible
and some are not I mean if I say okay so
are they all capable of a make dynamic
presumably yes every one of them it's a
little weird that that is some that it's
just says shift key not shift key
pressed or something um okay
well I agree that current value is a
good place for some of these things I
mean the font being used I don'ts done
what is front being used how does it
know what font is being used so this is
as Brett was implying or saying directly
actually this is where you can give it a
scope and so I mean if you don't say
anymore it will figure out the scope
from where the current value was being
evaluated if it's in a dynamic box and
it will look at the dynamic box's
environment for example but you can you
can give it other environments as well
it's like a cell object for example okay
but there's no font family here that's
totally weird
I mean it's giving you all this all this
random stuff which depends on font
family but yet the font family itself is
not there ooh that's because we don't
list the options and font family is an
option to what it's a front end option
and therefore it's it's readable and
settable in the same way that any front
end option is through core value in that
form oh my gosh
normally you would do it without the
quotes sweet but I mean we alias it so
it works okay with quotes
humph so women so any option from the
giant option inspector yeah so if I went
to line break within or some German yeah
oh boy
okay yeah this is this is a really
fundamental mechanism and it's used in
many many places in user interface
developments yeah yeah the current
values relationship to front-end options
okay but so the list of all font
families is not available as a current
value right now not not through a simple
string query no although arguably it
perfectly well could be as could this
could be yeah yeah so the real question
here is things that okay so let's take a
look at what isn't I mean things like
color schemes it seems very weird to
call those system data and we already
have this color data thing for them
although it's kind of a funky thing yeah
well in that case it depends on what you
mean by system do you mean the Wolfram
language system they are running in in
which case it makes a lot of sense or do
you mean the you know the the operating
system environment that you're in
computing system environment that you
mean the computer system like system
information yeah right system
information actually returns information
about
about both kinds of systems yes I
understand but so I mean arguably system
information should be able to be drilled
down to find out things like the
available voices that you have on your
computer system because that varies with
platform doesn't it yes it does and it's
not just my platform but you might also
be able to install extra voices in your
system support okay and Curly fonts can
depend on lots of that stuff yeah okay
all right so I want to come back to this
again okay another thing that has been
asked for here so okay so one thing is
the programmatic discovery basically of
these long lists another thing that's
been asked for is some kind of filtering
mechanism based on some kind of tags so
for example if you want to filter your
font families based on whether the font
is modest based yes as an example yes
right so I mean you know one pattern we
don't have is for each of these things
you know okay so another mechanism we
need is properties
of choices so in other words eg eg get
an association
associated with a voice font etc now we
have that for the voices right shaadi is
that correct yes how do I get that by
the way if you have a prototype built
its voice style data bracket bracket
okay
you
you
okay so that let's just note that there
and then in fact this voice style dealer
has the mechanism to pick from the list
so you can say hash language equals
English and it just gives you English
languages for voices so you're saying if
I go in here and I say hash language
equals equals
handily yeah do something okay okay so
that's a select on that but so so the
general mechanism that we probably want
is a way to associate
okay so given a font we could imagine a
similar Association right yes which by
the way could have all of those
properties that are in the current value
documentation of X Heights and all that
kind of thing to send us all those sorts
of things
no because some of that information is
dependent on specific instantiation of
the font and size even yeah presumably
on size yeah but there are some
properties which are which are global
you know I mean that the amount of space
can be an example and it's serifs and oh
I forget the others but there are a few
others that we already keep track of
okay fine but so what we need then is a
selector effectively for I see I mean so
so okay there are two things we need to
be able to get given the voice find its
properties okay so objectives you know
given a thing eg voice find its
properties
and the second thing is filter on the
list of all things eg voices for a
certain select criterion basically it's
that right yes okay so the first thing
is given a thing find its properties now
how do we think we might do that
in any generality I mean in the case of
current value if we've got a bunch of
strings that are fonts how on earth
would we specify to find their
properties unless so another another
whole mechanism for all of this stuff is
should we use entities and when should
we use entities for example should fonts
be entities
if other entities then then all of this
stuff with properties I mean if we used
entities then that problem is solved
then we take the entity you know and
we're doing you know entity property we
also can do things like we would be able
to do things like entity you know font
and then well how would we do this is
Alan here by the way yeah um how would
we do
bandura look up yeah I'm trying to look
up how do I do a lookup that says
something is equal to something
something goes to something else oh yeah
yeah right right right so San serif
yeah that's exactly what we would get to
do and that would then give us the list
of entities you know font entities with
with them so that's the next question is
could all of these things that we're
talking about reasonably be considered
to be answer days
I mean fonts presumably could be
so these would be entities that we would
have to construct on the fly and they
might not map to global entities or they
Matt might map incorrectly to global
entities so that I mean these really
would have to be private entities I
think and I really haven't worked with
those so I don't know don't know what
what do you mean constructed on the fly
well okay so first of all you want the
fonts that are available on this system
the you know and you may not have you
know just because you have a font or the
given name doesn't mean that you have
the same font with the given name that
might is in some global registry
somewhere you know you might have you
might have your own thing which has
different properties or you might have a
font family that it doesn't exist in any
global registry so they between those
two issues it seems like they really
have to be private entities right so
that means all the information you would
need to construct that set of entities
exist in some programmatically
retrievable form yes I am just exactly
okay so I mean Victor then it wouldn't
be that hard to have a had to generate a
custom entity store from that data if we
wanted that to exist i suture saying so
so then i see it and then register the
entity store yeah that's yet is it is
there overhead in this process yes I
mean some immense but but some I mean
the reason I asked is because you can't
even you can't even count on the you
know the list of font families being the
same now in 60 seconds from now I mean
it usually is but how would you expect
that that's
well I mean what we do right now is we
do it the expensive way you know we we
only make the requests when you when you
make query I we have something that's
more efficient that's inside the menus
because we don't want to be rebuilding
menus all the time obviously but but in
terms of you know what dollar farm
families does just you know it does
something that might be modestly
expensive but right now it's not that
expensive because it's only getting
names it's not doing any fights
so as Allen points out entity store is
the thing that we can you know we have a
whole mechanism for creating an entity
store and registering it now that
registration doesn't in in terms of
selecting a particular font yeah I mean
hmm we will presumably allow both the
common name which would be just the
string name of the thing yeah I mean
that's interesting for musical
instruments that's a pretty constant
list and we could perfectly well have an
an entity store for that unfortunately
the problem is there are actual musical
instruments out there in the wild like
for example you know control equals
mandolin for example which is recorded
as a musical instrument there about
which we have a bunch of properties
right and I bet we do not correctly map
those into MIDI instruments do you think
we do
you
you
sorry the question do we have it
remapping right now between instruments
young buddy
codes I don't know I can't remember
what the heck is that mmm I don't know
if that's a data issue or a data set
issue that's a data status you I think
yeah with intervals of quantities yeah
okay pause can you pick that up
I did okay um well okay so that doesn't
contain the mapping I mean I don't know
what the complete set of musical
instrument says we could presumably find
out
and by the way I mean the fact that we
have all of this apparatus for okay so
we've got a bunch of stuff there that
will definitely not be found in the in
this default thing here correct
[Music]
and we're going to need a mechanism to
determine
let me just capture this point here
we're going to need a mechanism to
you know these are specific
middy renderable instruments I mean we
clearly this list is a list of MIDI
instruments
hmm okay Alan do you have any thoughts
here I mean it in gosh you see I mean
the entity mechanism is a good one for
having an ability to list properties
having an ability to select things as
you say you can build an entity store on
the fly that's all good
[Music]
the disadvantage of that is well what is
the disadvantage so in this case here we
would end up with something like entity
we'd say something like entity well we
could say something like system voice
blah blah blah and here we could
potentially say entity system musical
instrument making sense yeah and even
system for
does that mean the wrong thing John no I
would be comfortable with that okay so
then the way one would do it I mean if
one wanted to find out what are all the
voices that are available you would say
entity list of system voice just not
completely terrible by any means and
that gives you a bunch of entities and
then you query each entity and we've got
a well-defined mechanism for selecting
ones that have certain properties so
that's all good okay so let's take a
look at some of the other things here so
fonts musical instruments voices they
all seem to potentially work as entities
do we agree
yeah I think so yeah I think it's it's
quite elegant to be able to do that with
you know to have the fonts be entities
um it's quite an elegant thing actually
because you know we can even imagine
doing some linguistics and things like
that on that okay let's take a look at
some of the other things here okay
colour schemes can color schemes be
entities don't see why not
okay so that would be then system colour
schemes will be the name for that okay
so Alan let's talk about your entity
documentation stuff mm-hmm
could that be used to document these
system entities seems like it could and
we just know how that would mmm
you I guess so you mean with a with a
caveat that entity list of whatever this
entity is gonna be different on
everybody's individual computer that's
what I'm saying yes I guess so
okay I think devices we not sure go
ahead
no yeah we choose some pick some
reasonably generic machine to run it on
to generate the thing
yeah okay I mean I pretty much like the
solution I think I think devices is a
different story and we shouldn't mess
with that and one thing that I've
somebody else has pointed out to me on a
side channel here what about what
happens when you want to use one of
these system entities and you've got
some code that includes one of those in
a notebook and you want to share that
with somebody else and they don't have
it that person doesn't have the same set
of system entities well what happens
right now when the okay so that that's
another thing okay so let's talk about
that for a minute so another issue is
okay
so system dependent is basically what do
we call it the font substitutions
business for example substitutions for
absent system and today's right so so
John you've got a mechanism for font
substitutions correct that's correct
how does that work well first of all
it's recorded as a global option or
might even be work at the notebook level
I'd have to look that up but in any case
the so it can be configured by users but
typically it's configured at the you
know it's the default configuration by
the way X covering the autocomplete for
current value is not covering its
strings the you know I'm saying it's not
covering the that's this right and I
mean you know like I said you know we
allow you to alias these things as
strings but the preferred way to work
with them as symbols then you know what
I think I think card value should have
some kind of pick up because it's got
too many of these choices well but but
if you have some sense of which way
you're going then then we're actually
limiting the number of choices I mean
you know if you're typing it without the
string we're not showing all the string
selectors and vice versa
and you could argue whether or not
that's a good idea but it certainly does
help the limit choices you know if you
type in some without the string you're
only getting options you're not no I
never notice this line here I'd never
noticed it maybe we
just make a table here and I don't know
whether the examples show this no they
absolutely do not show this looking no
look under scope
yeah I'm sure scope does show it yeah
but I think you should show that more
obviously right in the basic examples I
can do that but people are not unaware
of this I mean there are a lot of real
users who are who were who are doing
this you know inside the company so all
right let's look at the substitutions
okay so where do these come from and and
what happens to some random font on my
system if I say random sample well
because I have these well I mean so in
answer to where it comes from you know
the default value is literally a
hard-coded lists which was which was
created by design and R&D okay
probably a long time ago by now it gets
tweaked now and that now I I think it
last got tweaked Oh sometime in the last
couple of years I think ok so one
possibility for this will be destroy
these in the data repository store the
substitutions yeah and where we're gonna
store them because there's got to be a
big you know these substitutions change
with time ultimately version I mean so
it's important when we added font with
version 11 we changed the table quite a
bit so I on the built-in front yeah oh I
see so we have certain built in phones
so that the right-hand side of this is
built-in phones is that true not always
but if it's not then it you know then it
is you know something which either has a
decent chance of being present or it
chains to another thing you know so it
is possible you you may not your first
hit might not be present but then it
just substitutes again
and and and we do have these you know
they are different list for the
different platforms and the reason for
that is because you know the different
platforms have different expectations
about what we have on Cisco the way
brett why are these circles so damn big
I don't know perhaps you could check out
to check with Charles but this is kind
of interesting actually in fact this is
a pretty good example of in fact we
should definitely give this example when
we have when we have the page for phone
substitutions she stops scrolling for a
moment so I grab a screenshot yep think
you got it um it's kind of interesting
that that particular thing
this is telling us
yo so the question is now what do we
want this to look like in the wild so to
speak what do we want this to look like
is this specific to my computer no it's
it's a global list right it's a global
list but it is specific to you know this
is the default list for macintosh it is
going to be different under windows and
and under linux so as a hard-coded thing
yeah so to me it seems like it will be
and so you can see a good example that
right there in the the small group on
the right where you have lots of things
going to Menlo Menlo is a font that
every Macintosh has but you will
generally not find this font on Windows
or Linux and so on Windows for example
you know the console s which is on the
outside right now that'll get inverted
and consulates will be on the inside
okay all right
so the same thing might be true for
system voices right as for system fonts
correct so every one of these things
needs to go off where are some other
cases where we have such graphs
coercion graph of it's like a type
coercion growth
was it the musical instruments
for the longest identity musical
instrument to MIDI well I don't know you
know if you don't have a mandolin use a
violin pretty unconvincing to me
but yeah there may be some that are sort
of yeah but then even for voices you
could have some some voices that doesn't
map to anything you have a Hindi on Nike
if there is no Hindi on Windows there is
no substitution
what do you do for fonts I mean there's
always a substitution for fonts so if
there is no substitution that we provide
and the font doesn't exist then the font
or then the system font chooser figures
it out okay okay all right so okay so
okay how are we going to do this where
are we going to put the substitution
tables so each category of entity each
entity type might have a substitution
table I don't think we have an entity
store any kind of global thing right in
an NC store so far as I know everything
that's there has to be tied to a
particular entity or another is that
true what what do you mean you mean that
there's metadata about the type or yes
that's what I'm saying this metadata in
this case there's a substitution table
between the entities
that says if somebody asks for this
entity if somebody okay the the case
that we're really concerned about is
transportability
you
okay transport ability between systems
either a particular platform doesn't
have has stuff missing or a particular
user's machine has stuff missing right
those are the two cases
yeah for the things that for the classes
of things that we've talked about so far
yes well and how could that happen I
mean it could happen there could be a
version skew problem that some kind of
color data thing isn't available see
some of the stuff like color data we can
potentially patch it in but for a font
you're kind of toast right there's no
way we can give that to you patch it
into your system correct or not correct
we have no mechanism for that now and
fonts you know frequently cost money and
you know not trivial money yeah right so
it's not technically totally unfeasible
but did you know that technical feature
might violate a license um okay
all right okay fine but so so what do we
do with this transportability thing so
you you're on a system you don't have
that font you got to default to
something where do we keep this table
I think we're discovered the styling
right now
that mostly we will have entity stores
which are entity things that will be in
packets they won't be in the data
repository that will be the way that we
represent like fonts for example there
will be entity stores that are
constructed on the fly from tables or
code in packets but they also need
substitution tables somewhere to deal
with this I mean Allen what's the
analogy to this with our external
reference you know what are we calling
this now the external reference and
today's
external identifier right right so okay
so the point about an external
identifier okay so question for fonts is
there a global registry of fonts in some
sense is there a UUID for a font no so
it's just its name and do you have it or
not on your system I mean you could you
know collect some other properties about
it but can you open an app on your Mac
called font book it should be there haha
cool Steven writing regular I wonder
whether we ever used that I'm now
curious where that can I run this now if
the font is visible where does that mean
that I can say style but now it doesn't
autocomplete you know it's fine family
you can't just put a random string in
because what is that string mean you
have to ask me right hand side of font
family there is the bar oh my god oh my
gosh I had no idea huh okay it's pretty
grainy is there a better way to do this
by the way oh look at that ex-con that
had to have a substitution yeah I'm
sorry a better way to do what
oh just timed writing I I don't know it
might be useful one day right this is so
if you go back to font book you know in
the top left corner of that window
there's a little information button yes
and
it's you know some of the information
that the system knows about that font
there the meta information I see so this
is the kind of thing which would be
extractable for use in the association
yes
try looking at a font other than yours
you'll get a lot more stuff yeah okay
how do I look at the font on there I'm
not most stuff yeah maybe you look at
something like Arial I don't know if
that will have more oh yeah yeah okay
what do our own fonts which by the way
we should rename the mathematical fonts
yeah yeah look under all fonts oh no I'm
sorry I'm sorry they're not here they're
not here because they're not globally
installed into the system I see because
that will be a nuisance to do yes and it
causes problems with version skew as
well so but so wait a minute so that
means if I copy something which is in
one of our fonts and to let's say word
no you know it doesn't work that way
okay
the you can't you you cannot in our
system at least not without kind of
deliberately trying to work around this
you cannot style something or you know
have a style that lives in our fonts in
some way and then lose that information
it's just all Unicode characters and
then we're just
I see I see yeah we're just rendering
those but so if you take a differential
D for example which I know whether that
still lives in private you new codes I
mean yeah yeah pretty sure it does yeah
so what happens when you go to
copy that into something which doesn't
have access to that which doesn't have a
remoraid so the there isn't there isn't
really any way you can do that the the
the the closest variant of the question
that you're asking is is you know could
I export it to say PDF or something like
that and in the case of PDF we do
actually embed the fonts or rather a
subset of the fact that is relevant but
I mean for text for example the you know
we're not going to copy that
as the actual Unicode character because
it wouldn't make sense to anyone else so
instead we can't be the long name so you
literally get backslash bracket
differential do you bracket okay
okay so I'm coming back now to this font
substitution thing okay so something has
arrived it's in you know Steven writing
font how do we do on the target machine
what do we do with that well so you know
so that's that's a font that we know
nothing about as far as rendering is
just gonna go to this system and do
whatever you know whatever thing that
system font user is doing as far as our
queries of it I mean the only thing that
we can say is that we know manifestly
nothing about this no I get that but I'm
saying what even is the substitution how
does it know that this is a you know if
we know okay so you just do the
experiment you know so do the same thing
with Brett writing instead of Steven
writing and you think it will think the
one I want to just do an error it's not
gonna give an error
I see but if the metadata says it's a
sans font it'll replace it the system
sands or serif the system serif it'll
get that close right no well but it
doesn't have any of that information
no there's nothing to work with I mean
you know the the front end tries various
strategies you know as far as the claim
goes I think that even is this because
that's a property of the Steven writing
fonts okay
but yeah so in this case you know the
front end looked for any information
from the system or from far
substitutions it completely failed and
it just said okay I'm just gonna pass
the string Brett writing to the
operating system and let the operating
system do whatever it will do it's a
totally weird list of languages it has
the SEZ SEZ style regular which might be
what it got the ex-con from or does that
just mean the italic bold whatever yeah
it's the weight and that sort of thing
yeah so it's pretty random here my guess
is that the exclam was probably plugged
in as some kind of default thing from
the font afire program yes okay fair
enough okay
so yet again uh I mean how sophisticated
should we be in these substitutions for
system entities maybe we should
good as we can be and and expect that
it's hard code well I mean what we're
doing in in practice you know I think is
very defensible and if you find a way to
translate that into you know system
entity queries I would have no problem
with that
right except that we don't have a global
thing with an entity store right we
don't have global metadata for an entity
store which is what this would need
right I mean potentially we could add
that a property of an entity type I'll
undo that I'm trying to they're trying
to look at this I think that there may
be it may be possible to have some
properties of types I'm not sure how
flexible those are I'm waiting for a
response from Tony okay fair enough we
should wrap this meeting I think we've
made good program let me just say that
this this just can't work for Styles
though I mean it's the the stuff we've
been talking about I think we can put
together something coherent for style is
a completely different category of thing
so just yes yes I'm not too concerned
about that I think that it's more okay
all right I think we have to wrap this
meeting I think we have made progress if
we could I know Alan is really busy
right now
what's the right place to try to
actually define this as entity stores I
mean we should make sure that we don't
have any other things that we're
forgetting in this list
I mean plot themes things like that you
know wait maybe we can do as an exercise
we can try and do musical instruments
plot themes and fonts using this
strategy and see how that works there
are different people
um sure they could take the lead on
musical instruments Brett on plot themes
and somebody enfants well that'd be a my
group parts I can figure out something
okay well let's try this and maybe can
get shot he can do voices as well so we
want some sort of local entity store
prototype II saying yes that's what we
want we want to see if this can work
with a local entity store okay and and
then we can simply use you know the
whole mechanism with data set and so on
and so on and so on to get all the
properties and we've got we've got
everything there all right I need to run
this was useful made progress this is
and style Pickers are one in SW notes
and I'll be can you get to it parth yes
I can um okay date kill soon